اذا نستعرض تطورات المعارك الميدانيه
بالتفصيل وابرزها القصف المتبادل
بالمسيرات في روسيا اعلنت وزاره الدفاع
استئناف العمل في مطارات موسكو بعد تعليقه
مؤقتا اثر هجوم بطائره مسيره اوكرانيه
قالت السلطات الروسيه انها اسقطتها في
منطقه استرا غرب موسكو في الاراضي الروسيه
ايضا اعلنت وزاره الدفاع عن اسقاط مسيره
في منطقه استرا في بيل جرود بينما اعلن
حاكم المقاطعه ان مدنيين اصيبوا جراء قصف
بالذخائر العنقوديه على الجانب المقابل
اعلنت السلطات في خركيف شمال الشرقيه
اوكرانيا اوكرانيا تدمير مسيرتين روسيتين
وفي الجبهات الاخرى تستمر المعارك
المباشره لا سيما في محيط باخموت وكوبيانس
التي تتعرض
لقصف روسيا مستمر حسب رئيس الاداره
العسكريه في